Speaker 1: Welcome back to the The
David Pakman Show. I am once again
Jesse Dallimore filling in for David
while he is not here to do the videos.
Right now we are facing a budget battle. We
are facing a debt ceiling increase battle
that Republicans are making hay over. They are
trying to score political points in an effort
to again create chaos and as much of it as they
can. Jim Sciutto had a guy named Dusty Johnson.
That's apparently his real name, Dustin Johnson,
Republican from South Dakota on. And Jim Sciutto
is doing a valiant job, a noble effort here,
attempting to get Congressman Dusty Johnson
to just name one one single program that he
wants to put on the chopping block to cut in
an effort to save the budget or whatever. He
gives him multiple times multiple chances to
do this. And the guy just flat out refuses using
some lame excuse about not wanting to negotiate
in public. And I'm not going to negotiate on TV.
The same thing we're hearing Kevin McCarthy say.
But it's very easy. If you want to be a
leader, you want to be a congressman, you
want to be someone who's in this budget battle,
making responsible choices about America and the
spending of taxpayer dollars. You should be able
to name at least one program that you think needs
to be revamped relative to spending. Watch this.
Speaker 2: So so first, on the budget demands of
your party here, what specific programs
are you putting on the table to cut?
Speaker 3: Well, that's not how a negotiation
works. And in fact, the law says that the
president needs to step forward with a budget
first. His team is going to miss their February
deadline. They say they're not going to get that
done until March. So here is what I think is
step one today. We need to have the president
and the speaker in the same room that's going
to happen. And we need to have President Biden
agree that he will negotiate over the reckless
spending that our country has been engaged in.
Speaker 2: But as you know, the debt ceiling
relates to budgets already passed by Congress,
including with Republican votes. What are
the positions? Because a negotiation, as you
know, involves, if you want to call it that,
involves two sides presenting their positions.
Can you name a single program that Republicans
would be willing to cut money from to make a deal?
Speaker 3: But see, I think that's ridiculously
unfair. And here's why. The credit card bill
comes to our family. We have maxed out our
credit cards. Now, of course, listen, we're
going to pay that credit card bill. We're
legally obligated to do so. But rather than
force all of the onus on the Republicans,
which I know you all love to do, what a
responsible, reasonable and sensible family
would do is sit down together. And by.
Speaker 1: The way, I'm not doing.
Speaker 2: That.
Speaker 3: To stop.
Speaker 1: I don't want putting.
Speaker 2: All the onus on Republicans. That's
the law. The law puts the onus on Congress and the
nation to pay its bill. But but please go ahead.
Is there a program that you can name that you
personally would be willing to see money cut from?
Speaker 3: Well, yeah, there are lots
of programs, but but the point is,
I'm not going to negotiate against the
Republican Party on CNN. The only thing that
we're asking for today is for President Biden to
be responsible, sensible and reasonable and being
willing to come to the table and negotiate.
Speaker 1: So, Mr. Thumbing with ears, Dusty
Johnson refuses to answer even one single program.
And his little his cute little family analogy
just doesn't hold water. A family can't print
money. Budgets. It's not a 1 to 1 comparison,
and anyone who acts like it is is pulling the
wool over your eyes about how simplistic it is.
It's a complex macroeconomic system we
have here. And budgets are like, Well,
I got a mortgage, I got a credit card bill and
I got my grocery bill. And it's not how it works
and he knows it. Mr. Thumbs with ears knows
it. It is it is disingenuous, to say the least